vielen dank für die ankündigung kann man
es gut sehen geht es so genau als ich
werd zu beginn was aus philosophischer
perspektive berichten
ich denke es passt ganz gut dass wir
wieder philosophie anfangen weil die
philosophie ja sagte man früher
zumindest so die königin aller
wissenschaften ist das kann sie heute
schon lange nicht mehr beanspruchen
aber sie ist zumindest vielleicht die
problematische wissenschaft und es gibt
sogar diesen die hier auch an der lmu
münchen vertreten werden dass
philosophie gar keine wissenschaft ist
und wenn die philosophie jetzt keine
wissenschaft ist dann stellt sich die
frage kann sie dann überhaupt methoden
haben für die lehre gibt es
verbindlichkeiten nicht nur im inhalt
sondern eben auch was die vermittlung
von inhalten anbelangt und ich habe
jetzt fünf punkte zu denen ich hier im
folgenden in der nächsten halben stunde
etwas sagen möchte erstmal zur
didaktischen herausforderungen der
philosophie habe ich schon ein bisschen
was dazu gesagt dann möchte ich schnell
übergehen zur digitalen transformation
der philosophie ich möchte also
versuchen zu zeigen dass ich aus dem
wesen aus der problematik der
philosophie als disziplin besondere
chancen ergeben für die digitalisierung
die digitale transformation da möchte
ich im anschluss drei projekte zeigen
kurz demonstrieren die ich seit einem
jahr hier ausprobiert habe wurden
freundlicherweise auch finanziert von
lehrern eu haben das multiplikatoren
projekts und durch profil habe ich dafür
profitieren können das ist einmal das
blockseminar dann ist es einmal das wiki
seminar und ganz zuletzt der finowkanal
von dem sie auch hier auf ihrem tisch
einen kleinen flyer finden
ich komme jetzt mal zum ersten punkt es
ist gar nicht so klar was eigentlich
philosophie ist und deswegen ist es auch
gar nicht so klar wie die didaktik der
philosophie auszusehen hat ich habe
jetzt mal ein paar gedanken gemacht was
ich glaube was philosophie ist das ist
richtig da gibt es auch andere thesen
aber ich habe es mal so ein paar punkte
aufgezählt die so auch durch den gang
der geschichte immer wieder vertreten
wurden also philosophie ist könnte man
sagen
sie argumentativ kontroversen
problemorientiert es scheint mir ganz
wichtig zu sein philosophie ist arbeit
am begriff arbeit an ganz grundlegenden
problemen die noch nicht eingang in
wissenschaften gefunden haben und dort
zb empirisch dann erschließbar sind das
ist in der philosophie teilweise
vielleicht der fall aber nicht so sehr
dann würde ich weiteren punkt nennen es
ist begrifflich es versucht begriffe
logisch zu klären zu ordnen zu
systematisieren also ordnung in dieses
wirrwarr zu bringen ordnung in das
unwissen zu bringen in die unklarheit
dann hängt damit zusammen analytisch
logisch klären und differenzieren also
noch stärker differenzieren und dann
aber glaube ich auch was ganz wichtig
ist philosophie sollte nicht nur
analytisch sein sind auch synthetisch
also wenn man mal die begriffe
analysiert hat oder probleme
identifiziert hat systematischer
sachprobleme die wieder mit anderen
problemen in eine beziehung bringen und
damit vernetzen so dass wir nicht nur
ein detail blick auf einzelne probleme
haben sondern den großen zusammenhang
nicht aus den augen verlieren ich glaube
diese zwei tendenzen diese zwei
richtungen das analytische und
synthetische im begrifflich diskursiven
das könnte man sagen macht so die
philosophie auf einem sehr allgemeinen
niveau und das ist jetzt die frage wie
wir jetzt angesichts dieser situation
der philosophie in die lehre übergehen
also wie können wir jetzt nicht die
frage
angesichts dieser grundtendenz der
philosophie methoden identifizieren
lehrmethoden diese glauben eine
philosophie unterricht an hochschulen
und universitäten aber nicht nur dort
vielleicht auch mit kindern möglichst
adäquat möglichst der disziplin
entsprechend durchzuführen
und ich glaube man kann es auf den
begriff bringen dass philosophie ein
selbst bezüglich des verwaltungssystem
ist das ist in der jüngsten zeit immer
mehr klar geworden also philosophie
bringt begriffe in eine ordnung sie
klärt begriff bezieht sie aber zugleich
auf andere begriffe und ich habe sie
sehen ich habe das jetzt hier schon so
ein bisschen hier hypertext realisiert
also meine these oder meine absicht ist
in folgen zeigen dass man in der lehre
der philosophie sehr viel über solche
verweisung systeme machen kann über
solche huber links wie ich sie hier
jetzt gerade am angezeigt habe und ich
will jetzt mal so ein paar beispiele
gleich bringen zur digitalen
transformation der philosophie also da
soll der hypertext eine ganz große rolle
spielen wie sie in den letzten semestern
gehandelt habe in meinen projekten
was kann denn so eine digitale
transformation der philosophie erreicht
sie kann wenn wir jetzt sagen
philosophie ist wesentlich diskursiver
kontroverse natur
sie kann zum beispiel diskussionen
dokumentieren und abbilden mir ist es
häufig so ergangen in meiner lehre dass
ich das gefühl hatte die seminar
diskussion war jetzt wirklich toll und
da ist auch wirklich was dabei
rausgekommen aber eine halbe stunde nach
dem ende des seminars ist alles verpufft
es ist weg dass sie alles in der luft
tolle ideen tolle gedanken aber
irgendwie nicht verbindlich
und das finde ich einfach schade weil
ich denke es geht so viel verloren und
die herausforderung ist jetzt also die
für die digitale leere
wie können wir die kontroversen
diskussionen die sich in einem seminar
idealerweise eigener philosophie wie
können wir die adäquat dokumentieren
abbilden so dass der lebendige
kontroverse diskussion dialektische
vielleicht sogar charakter dieser
diskussion angefangen wird und möglichst
adäquat abgebildet wird und nicht wie
schon platon meinte durch die schrift
fixiert und so etwas scheinbar
unhinterfragt barren kristallisiert oder
verfestigt wird das wollen wir nicht
sagen wir wollen den lebendigen
gedankengang der sich im seminar
diskussion geeignet den wollen wir
möglichst adäquat fassen oder
transformieren ja wie kann das jetzt von
statten gehen das möchte ich im
folgenden so ein bisschen bezeichnet ich
habe jetzt hier schon ein bisschen was
von fred gegriffen also begriffe
fangnetzen über textuelle strukturen
schaffen eine philosophische landkarte
sicher arbeiten das hat so ein bisschen
was vom 1
map wir bringen begriff in ordnung und
dann war es mir auch ganz wichtig ist
diskussionen die er für philosophie
zentral sind man kann über alles
diskutieren das muss mir gewisse ordnung
haben diese diskussionen und raum
zeitlich unabhängig von dem
universitätsstandort fortführen das war
mir auch ein ganz großes anliegen
also zwei punkte nicht nur im
seminarraum hier diskutieren und danach
alles irgendwie vergessen schöne
erinnerungen haben war doch toll sondern
das was man sich gemeinsam im diskurs
erarbeitet hat das irgendwie zu
dokumentieren auf eine noch näher
auszuführen device und dann aber ganz
wichtig die diskussion nicht einfach
abbrechen lassen nachdem jetzt die 90
minuten rum sind sondern sie medialen
fall fortführen
wie kann man das machen diese
philosophische diskussion nicht nur
philosophisch man kann sagen diskussion
überhaupt die an universitäten und
hochschulen stattfinden
wie kann man die raum zeitlich
unabhängig von dem jeweiligen
hochschulstandort weiterführen das ist
so eine herausforderung ich glaube dass
hier die digitalen medien uns ganz tolle
möglichkeiten bieten das zu tun
und das möchte ich jetzt im folgenden
mal kurz zeigen anhand meines ersten
projekts ist die sogenannte blockseminar
das hatte ich im sommersemester 2016
durchgeführt da war hornschall der vorne
sitzt meine kraft dem ich sehr viel zu
verdanken habe
wir haben ja so ein konzept uns
erarbeitet blockseminar also nicht
blockseminar ist ein blockseminar es
besteht aus dem traditionellen seminar
mit einem blog was angebunden ist und
noch mit einer app die da auch noch
daran gebunden ist eine 3d struktur und
die sollen dann in der summe im
zusammenspiel zusammengeschmolzen
transformiert sondern neue seminar vom
ergeben das war mir so ein versuch
erzählt jetzt mal ein bisschen näheres
dazu wir haben hier komme auf die app
gab es von google places dort gab es
beim app store von apple
wir haben im blog gemacht das sieht so
aus das thema war philosophische
theorien des lebens so müssen wir das
2016 wir haben hier so eine
gottesanbeterin genommen die schien uns
am besten dieses thema zu verkörpern
sie sehen hier schon so manche
strukturen hier so ein
inhalts menü seminarplan dokumente unter
weiterhin gibt es im login-bereich wo
sich die mitglieder die hatten so eine
zugangskennung konnten sich registrieren
hier ist ein kalender wo neue aktuelle
dinge angekündigt werden und hier gibts
schlagworte die je nach häufigkeit der
nennung sich auf pläne tag wolke hier
sehen sie so einen beitrag als es
bestand darin die seminarteilnehmer
sollten einfach anstatt von referaten
oder im anschluss von referaten sollten
sie ihren beitrag hier eigenständig auf
dieses blog stellen
dann gab es die möglichkeit der anderen
studierenden diesen beitrag zu bewerten
sowie bei amazon also der hat hier ganz
der hat nur eine bewertung mittlerweile
hatte mehr
also gab es dann noch mal 4,5 4,2 bei
meinen referat bei meinen beiträgen gab
es nicht also 3,5 3,6 sie waren mit
abstand die schlechtesten also die von
den teilnehmern waren die besten und sie
sehen hier schon hier sind zwei begriffe
sind schon so hypertext ul eingebunden
es gibt ja auch noch einen viking hier
wir haben alle wichtigen begriffen so
ein wikipedia system eingespeist das war
so das blog die blogs struktur wir haben
corporate design gemacht sie haben sie
haben's gesehene gab so eine mantis die
biologinnen und biologen unter ihnen
wissen gottesanbeterin des die mantis
und wir haben gedacht da machen wir uns
mal ein maskottchen daraus das
maskottchen und das ist dabei
herausgekommen das ist die mentee die
uns hilft und das ist die menschen die
uns motiviert also wir haben versucht
das ganze ist ein bisschen ein bisschen
auch locker zu gestalten nicht allzu
streng bisschen ironie hineinzubringen
ja wir haben auch tassen und so als im
merchandising hängt eine ganze menge
noch dran aber worauf wir glaube ich
ganz besonders stolz waren war die app
die wir gemeinsam entwickelt hatten also
es gab daneben eine kostenlose app sie
sehen hier das ist wieder diese
gottesanbeterin hier ist ein menü hegels
verschiedene symbole die erkläre ich
noch ganz kurz also wir hatten zur
orientierung so war es ein
ausrufezeichen also wichtig
informationen die gab es auch per push
notification also ich hab den ein oder
anderen studenten morgens um 9 uhr aus
dem bett gepusht
haben die mir auch gesagt na also wenn
es mal wieder eine zusammenfassung
gehabt dann wurde die geschickt das ist
ein wiki eintrag das sind die
orientierung symbole
das ist leitfragen für die nächste
sitzung des seminars das technisches
formales also hausarbeiten wie viel
zeichen usw konnte man eine neue meldung
rein bringen das ist wieder das
hypertext welle wir haben versucht
begriffe auch grafisch in ordnung zu
bringen also mind maps als bilddateien
auch noch einzustellen und auch noch
weiterführende legen ist zum beispiel
auf youtube videos auf irgendwelche
homepages die sonst noch gab in der
thematik die philosophie des lebens gab
es natürlich vielen ehen zur biologie
damals externe inhalte gehabt und hier
sehen sie dann wie man jetzt von sollen
app begriff hypertext duell auf den
anderen begriff als im wiki system
verwiesen wurde man klickt dort mann
berührte diesen begriff und kam dann
hier auf den seelen begriff und von dort
konnte man dann wieder weiter springen
als es dann zum beispiel die
zusammenfassung von einer sitzung über
aristoteles aus genau das habe ich schon
erzählt dass es sind so diese beiträge
die die studierenden einspeisen konnten
man konnte das bewerten und man konnte
es auch verschlagworten wie man hier
noch sieht also mit anderen begriffen
wie jetzt hans jonas kant organismus
urteilskraft es gab der verschiedene
funktionen diese den inhalt möglichst
vielseitig zu vernetzen einzubinden ja
ganz kurz noch zu valuation also wie
häufig wurde die benutzt diese
blockseminar seite pro woche als sie
sehen hier so zwei bis dreimal häufigste
also jetzt nicht täglich aber durchaus
man ist immer mal wieder drauf gekommen
ich habe dieses poster auch im poster
präsentationsraum da finden sie die
ganze statistik auch noch wenn sie es
interessiert die app ähnlich also zwei
bis drei mal wurde die app pro woche
benutzt also es war ganz okay
geschlechter waren wir sehr zufrieden 20
also c also 50 prozent männlich 50
weiblich das bei uns sehr recht dass
also das offensichtlich für alle
geschlechter
intuitiv zugänglich war und gerne
genutzt wurde
genau so viel zum blockseminar jetzt
noch zum schluss über zwei weitere
projekte im wintersemester haben wir
dann ein weiteres seminar gemacht das
ist wirklich seminar und da hatten wir
versucht den fokus stärker auf begriffe
und auf vernetzungen von termini zulegen
so sieht es dann aus wir hatten hier
wieder so ein logo gemacht stärker
begriffs zentriert nicht so sehr
grafisch gestaltet auch da hatten wir
wieder eine app und hier kam jetzt neu
dazu dass wir jetzt auch die möglichkeit
hatten an beiträge direkt in der app zu
kommentieren also ein beispiel wir haben
jetzt hier ein beitrag von einem
gewissen maße lnu ich weiß nicht wer das
ist also hier jungen gefühl und vernunft
das war ein seminar beitrag ist in der
app ersichtlich greift auf das blog
zurück und jetzt schreibt hier ein
gewisser hier oben sehen sie die
kommentare da wurden zwei kommentare
dazu geschrieben hier ein gewisser jonas
r schreibt hier einen kommentar dazu
und man kann jetzt hier auch wieder in
der app hier wieder einen kommentar dazu
verfassen also das war noch stärker
begriffs arbeit die uns da wichtig war
und jetzt ganz zum schluss ganz neu
hatten wir uns überlegt das ganze mal
noch ein bisschen mehr mit videos in
verbindung zu bringen also nicht nur
jetzt textarbeit nicht nur kommentieren
sondern das ganze mal auch mit einem
bild mit videos zu transformieren und
was herausgekommen ist es viel okas das
ist also ein eigener youtube-kanal das
ist auch auf diesem flyer den sie da vor
sich zehn zu finden
das ist ein kanal in dem regelmäßige
themen sendungen gesendet werden oder
angeboten werden themen sendung zu allen
möglichen fragen auch und das war so
unser ziel möglichst zu fragen die im
seminar nicht mehr behandelt werden
oder fragen zu themen die vielleicht
eine art hintergrund bilden von
spezieller und seminarthema also zum
beispiel jetzt philosophie des lebens
könnte man fragen wie ist es eigentlich
darwins evolutionstheorie könnte da mal
eine kurze sendung machen und dann
würden wir uns als dozenten vorbereitet
darauf und in einem kurzen beitrag der
nicht länger als fünf bis zehn minuten
ist versuchen das im gespräch mit jemand
anderem darzustellen also es ist eine
weiterführung der seminar diskussion und
so ein kanal so eine plattform bietet
geben die möglichkeit dass man nicht nur
selbst als dozierende beiträge drauf
stellt sondern dass man auch jetzt
gerade im fall der philosophie bekannte
philosophin und philosophen gewinnt für
ein thema wir hatten da den fall dass
eine tagung hier hatten es waren
bekannte philosophin und philosophen und
haben wir einfach mal gebeten kommt doch
mal kurz hier in unser hinterzimmer wir
haben da so ein kleines studio
eingerichtet
einfach haben also überfallen und die
haben alle zugesagt und dann haben
gesagt setzen sie sich mal dahin wir
haben paar fragen und dann haben die da
uns gute antworten gegeben und das hat
auch eine ganz gutes feedback bekommen
auf youtube der vorteil bei youtube ist
eben der mann kann es viel besser
verlinken vernetzen mit facebook
verbinden man kann es per email schicken
das wissen sie alles man kann es
kommentieren
man kann eigene playlist erstellen also
youtube ist eine ganz ganz tolle
plattform für universitäts veranstaltung
finde ich natürlich setzt das immer
voraus dass die teilnehmer damit
einverstanden
diese ein für das einverständnis muss
man sich muss man einen holen aber das
vorausgesetzt ist das eine tolle
möglichkeit und man kann eben auch seine
eigenen lehrveranstaltungen kann man
aufnehmen oder auch gast vorträge sowie
in diesem fall jetzt und auch da haben
wir das dann wieder angebunden an so
eine app sondern viel oka step die man
sich auch herunterladen kann
das sehen sie jetzt mal den youtube
kanal also damals logo wir haben hier so
ein kurzes intro video und
ein paar abonnenten ist noch nicht so
viel wir freuen uns wenn wir noch ein
bisschen mehr abonnenten bekommen 55 ist
okay aber es soll luft nach oben
also so sieht er aus und die app sich
ganz ähnlich aus also da sehen sie so
normales video normales interview hier
dieses co ist ein quiz also es gibt ganz
tolle möglichkeiten sie kennen
sicherlich jobi captivate das ist ein
programm mit dem man sich multiple
choice quiz erstellen kann das eignet
sich auch für die philosophie um zum
beispiel knifflige fragen zu stellen wo
die antworten ganz nahe beieinander
liegen aber im entscheidenden moment auf
einander abweichen kann man die
teilnehmer glaube ich ganz gut
motivieren auch auf die nächste sitzung
oder zum beispiel passend zu einem text
den man aufs nächste mal zum lesen
aufgegeben hat ganz wichtige punkte
dieses textes abprüfen durch ein quiz
den quiz kann man auch zu beginn des
seminars machen um die teilnehmer zu
aktivieren also dass wir auch so eine
möglichkeit die app erlaubt es auch
diese krise von der app aus selbst zu
starten
er freue ich jetzt zum schluss kommen
noch eine einsicht in diese blogs
struktur was ich mir gezeigt hat im
laufe meiner bisherigen erfahrung ist
wenn man auf das internet setzt auf
digitale medien dann scheint mir das
allerwichtigste ist es sein dass man mit
möglichst wenig klicks zu den inhalten
kommt also ich sage jetzt einfach mal so
aus dem bauhaus pro weiterer klick
verliert man die hälfte der potenziellen
interessenten also das ist der grund
warum ich moodle im jetzigen stadium das
jetzt einfach mal eine these für nicht
gut geeignet halt für die hochschullehre
aus mehreren gründen man braucht drei
vier klicks man muss sich anmelden mit
einem konto man die navigation ist in
meinen augen noch nicht so übersichtlich
und man kann nicht alle funktionen
freischalten also man kann natürlich
ganz tolle dinge mit model machen man
kann multiple choice quiz es machen man
kann ein wiki system anlegen aber viele
dieser funktionen sind nicht gleich
freigeschaltet und man muss es sehr
aufwändig über administratoren dritte
seit dritter seite freischalten
eine andere möglichkeit wäre model
selbst zu hause
es geht also wenn sie sich über
wordpress ein paket hohe bei 1&1 oder
strato oder anderen anbietern können sie
kostenlos model selbst sich installieren
dann haben sie praktisch alle
zugriffsrechte aber das bietet sich
glaube ich auch nicht an weil wenn es
schon model gibt warum es nicht nutzen
also hier ist mein plädoyer oder meine
bitte wie auch immer meine these model
ist an sich ein gutes system aber es
muss ich noch viel ändern das muss
intuitiver sein es muss direkt
zugänglich sein es muss die funktion
viel freizügiger zur verfügung stellen
dann kann man ganz tolle dinge machen
weil model eben es auch erlebt erlaubt
benotungen durchzuführen wie bessere
statistiken zu erfassen als es hier
möglich ist diese sachen die ich hier
jetzt gemacht hatte mit herrn ohren
stammt die basierten auf wordpress basis
also alles kostenlos und frei das ist
sehr gut aber wird es hat auch seine
schattenseiten man muss aufpassen mit
der sicherheit dass man genug
sicherheits plugins installiert weil man
häufig auch angriffen ausgesetzt ist man
muss schauen dass man die richtigen
plugins hat um funktionen freizuschalten
und so weiter und so fort wordpress ist
nicht offiziell lmu das anderssein punkt
man muss ein interesse an einfügen und
die anbindung darstellt also das sind
alles solche dinge abschließend wer mein
wunsch einfach um einen impuls an die
hochschule oder hochschulen
grundsätzlich dass sie vielleicht eigene
wordpress seiten hausten eigenen
webspace jedem dozierenden zur verfügung
stellen möglichst schnell schneller
webspace 10 bis 20 gigabyte mit direktem
zugang vielleicht in zukunft auch eigene
apps ihre eigene app plattform zur
verfügung stehe stellt weil diese sachen
doch noch recht kostenintensiv sind da
mussten wir selbst aus der eigenen
tasche auch ein bisschen was zu schießen
das wäre glaube ich ganz toll und dann
ließe sich damit glaube ich sehr sehr
viel erreichen nicht nur für die
philosophie sondern für alle
geisteswissenschaften und vielleicht
sogar auch für die naturwissenschaften
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit